peace love and gratitude is something
that Ringo Starr is all about and the
music legend turns 80 today and he is
showing no signs of slowing down
Reagle how you doing man you look
fantastic
I work out I'm a vegetarian so a lot of
broccoli is in my diet
just keep moving
hard to believe Ringo was just 22 years
old when he joined the Beatles he's
still just as cool now rocking the same
signature shades he wore when we first
met him in 1981 I was a Beatle I'm still
Ringo Starr let me do my own records
name Ringo and Paul McCartney stayed
close performing together at the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame and tonight on
YouTube you'll get to see a mini Beatles
reunion as part of Ringo's annual peace
and love celebration combined with his
online 80th birthday bash I hear on this
we're gonna see never-before-seen
footage of you and Paul playing together
I went to Dodger Stadium last year and
played with Paul so it's never been out
never been seen what a brother brother
you know there's also a Beatles
connection to this song off pringles
latest album it was written by John
Lennon and Paul plays on the record it
was so great I mean I loved playing with
him you know he comes over to my studio
he's on most of my solo records I found
a song I think he's the only bass player
I can have on that track if it bit me
[Music]
yeah I'm sure I wrote it for Yoko but I
think it's you know it's open to
everybody you know it's emotional deep
inside you know I want John still to be
here but he's not hey John would have
been a tea also he would have been a tea
in October
what would he have been like at 80 I
don't know good old guy I think
[Music]
gringo who is still happily married to
former Bond girl Barbara Bach has
rescheduled his summer tour for next
year and all proceeds from his special
go to charities including black lives
matter
something the Beatles knew even back in
the day you guys refused to play a show
because they were gonna have a
segregated audience we didn't understand
it what do you mean you know people come
to the gig no I'm piece of love not
violence
[Applause]
[Music]